et je joins tout de suite monsieur chère
à la prairie où j ai tout juste de
terminer son discours bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir vous venez de faire un appel
très sentie aux québécois est-ce que
c'est pas un peu tard à six jours du
scrutin
pas du tout c'est nous avons un message
apprenant le camping que c'est le
gouvernement
c'est la partie constructeur qui peut
remplacer justin trudeau ce soir j'ai
souligné les les aspects que notre
plafond mais aussi le message que si les
québécois et québécoises but d'avoir des
députés
autour de la table des décisions c'est
le pratiqueront structure qui va
défendre les intérêts de ses provinces
mais c'était très émotif ce soir avait
touché toutes les cordes sensibles des
québécois la langue du nationalisme et
c'est ce que vous regrettez pas de la
vente de pas l'avoir fait avant parce
que là on voit cette montée du bloc
québécois qui pourraient vous priver de
votre majorité
mais j'ai toujours eu le plan de donner
un discours de cette magnitude et je
veux partager mon expérience avec avec
le québec avec le français pour pour
montrer que j'ai développé une respecte
sincère de les enjeux et les défis pour
une communauté une peuple française dans
une comptine anglophone est alors j'ai
parlé de mon expérience comme un enfant
avec mes parents faire des détours de
québec a pour pour montrer que c'est
vraiment une personne et je veux le
utiliser ces expériences comme premier
test pour assurer que les intérêts de d2
les québécoises et québécois sont
toujours pas seulement défendre mais
qu'on peut grandir ensemble aussi vous
avez même
évoquer le maître chez nous de jean
lesage mais les québécois vont pas être
maître des pipelines monsieur scheer
parce que vous voulez leur imposer votre
corridor énergétique
nous savons que les québécois et
québécoises préfère le pétrole de chez
nous nous nous servons c'est clair qu'il
ya aucune bon sens que les québécois
doit acheter l'énergie des états unis
quand on a beaucoup de ressources ici au
canada nous savons que c'est meilleur de
transporter le pétrole par les pipelines
au lieu de les chemins de fer alors je
suis sûr avec cette idée cette situation
cette solution gagnante-gagnante on peut
créer une façon de permettre le québec
de partager son hydro vers vers les
autres provinces
et aussi on peut arrêter l'importation
de la pas trop d'énergie étrangères se
sait je sais je suis convaincu que les
québécois va appuyer cette idée c'est
quand vous avez le meilleur rider sur
table les gens va te suivre mais si vous
former le gouvernement donc le 21
octobre vous croyez vous que ça vous
donne donc le feu vert selon vous pour
imposer ce corridor énergétique mais les
gens parlent toujours de s'imposer
d'imposer ce serait là une solution
n'est pas d'accord avec l'idée me plaît
il n'y a pas de stabilité sociale il y à
des milliers de kilomètres de pipelines
partout au canada et ici au québec et à
des milliers d emplois grâce à notre
secteur énergétique et ça va donner au
québec la possibilité de partager son
hydro les québécois sont fiers de son
idole il ya des besoins dans les autres
régions du canada
c'est une partenariat et quand nous
avons les standards en vente aussi à
lever endroits être en droit à ce que
nous sommes un pays où on peut
reconstruire les grands choses encore ça
va
assister plus nice et c'est sûr que
monsieur legault va vouloir avoir les
possibilités pour aix à exploiter
l'hydro c'est une partie de cette idée
c'est une vision pour l'épreuve pour le
calvaire le premier ministre l'a déjà
dit qu'ils ne voulaient pas qu'elle
n'avait pas besoin de l'hydroélectricité
du québec
donc est-ce que vous pouvez le forcer à
acheter l'hydroélectricité du québec
pour que ce soit gagnant gagnant comme
vous dites si bien que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup d amis et de famille en ontario
et v
les taux pour les régler les factures
diderot à elle avait extrêmement à graça
le désastreux bilan de le parti libéral
en ontario juste je sais juste que les
québécois que je préfère
l'énergie de chine russie s'est créé le
véhicule le plus populaire au québec
c'est la f150 et n'utilisez pas à le
sirop d'érable
c'est possible pour nous comme un pays
de réduire notre dépendance à l'énergie
étrangères
il n'y a aucune bonne raison pour
laquelle on doit importer acheter
l'énergie de l'économie de notre emprunt
doit envoyer notre argent à l'économie
des états unis et ces cinq questions de
leadership c'est une question d'une
vision pour notre pays et je suis
confiant qu'on veut le réaliser
mais si je vais vous croyez au
changement climatique oui absolument
alors pourquoi vous tenez tant à annuler
la taxe carbone simplement parce qu'elle
ne fonctionne pas cette plante cet axe
est rarement là prix pour les à
l'essence pour la chauffage domicile
pour les épiciers riz mais il ne réduit
pas nos émissions alors nous avons une
vraie plan pour l'environnement qui va
concentrer sur la lutte contre les
émissions dans un contexte global qui va
donner une un crédit d'impôt pour les
canadiens canadiennes des québécois et
québécoises pour les rénovation
écoresponsable et
et qui va investir dans la technologie
sas est une plante qui va réussir à
l'annexé ii commence simplement ne
fonctionne pas ouais mais est-ce que
c'est pas un peu d'entêtement politique
parce que beaucoup d'économistes le
fonds monétaire international encore la
semaine dernière a dit que c'était
vraiment un des outils les plus
puissants et les plus efficaces pour
lutter contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais il ne fonctionne pas
alors c'est pas mon opinion c'est pas
une une position philosophique
le parti conservateur c'est une farce et
les études officielles de la département
à 2 2 le directeur parlementaire du
budget de les les fonctionnaires dans le
gouffre rcc les analystes et les
chiffres et c'est pas notre opinion ne
fonctionne pas on va avoir une vraie
plan qui va concentrer sur lutter contre
les changements climatiques avec une
concentration des émissions globales
on peut produire beaucoup plus des
choses ici au cannet comme par exemple
l'aluminium
ici au québec avec notre énergie propre
on peut produire beaucoup plus de
l'aluminium avec beaucoup moins d
émissions
si cette même production effet au chine
alors si on peut réduire les émissions
dans un contexte global réduit le
montant de co2 dans l'atmosphère c'est
le but ça c'est l'objectif de notre plan
alors parlons de votre cadre financier
que vous avez présenté vendredi après
midi juste après le long congé de juste
avant le long congé de l'action de grâce
vous promettez d'équilibrer le budget en
cinq ans mais beaucoup d'économistes
craignent une récession mondiale
s'il y a six ont fait face à une
récession est ce que vous allez
prolonger un peu cet engagement retarder
cet engagement alors c'est et sociale
quand arrête la pratique d'être gourmand
actuelle libéral qui est on prône les
milliards et les meilleurs de la loire
et qui augmente les dépenses sur
l'intérêt de la dette nationale
à nous avons un plan responsable et
s'est basé sur le contexte économique
actuel et je dois noter que avec justin
trudeau
il a dépensé beaucoup d'argent quand les
temps sont bien et s'il ya une les défis
dans le futur on a pas maintenant la
flexibilité la capacité de gérer une des
filles alors l'accomplissement alors à
notre principe basé sur les chiffres
économiques actuelles avec les aléas
prédictions de tous les experts qui
donne la vie allez les conseils aux
gourmands fléron suis sûr qu'avec notre
plan on peut aider à la croissance
économique et baissé la coupe davis au
système central de notre plateforme
c'est de rendre la vie plus abordable
lesquels les québécois et québécoises
tous les canadiens sont hyper taxe et on
va réduire les épaules on va laisser
plus d'argent dans les poches de tous
les canadiens de tous les québécois et
québécoises rendre la vie plus abordable
alors parlons des compressions que vous
envisagez justement sur est-ce que c'est
pas un peu de la pensée magique de dire
que vous voulez réduire les dépenses en
fonctionnement du gouvernement
réduire de 5 milliards sans couper dans
les services s'est ses engagements et
sérénité veut simple parce qu'on va
continuer d'augmenter les
investissements pour les systèmes de
santé et d'éducation les autres
programmes sociaux comme ça mais on va
éliminer le gaspillage à toi alors comme
exemple il ya une phénomène à toi chaque
marché le march madness où tous les
départements dépense tout l'argent qui
reste dans la daaf dans la fin de
l'année fiscale elle achète les nouveaux
ordinateurs les nouveaux assauts l'hiver
les nouveaux chaises des choses comme ça
aussi il ya des contrats avec les
consultants extérieurs de l'est les
départements qui dans beaucoup de cas
fait le même travail que les
fonctionnaires à
bien expérience souvent des
fonctionnaires d'ailleurs qui reviennent
parce qu'on a besoin d'eux mais on va
protéger les emplois de fonctionnaires
parce qu'il ya une crypte les syndicats
des fonctionnaires publics qui disent on
a des gens qui peut faire le même
travail mais le département les
ministres engage les gens de des firmes
extérieures dépense beaucoup plus
dangereux quand il ya des fonctionnaires
avec beaucoup d'expérience à l'époque
celui dans le bon sens pour les services
vous vous engagez à ne pas couper dans
les violences dans les services c'est un
engagement très clair
chaque année on va augmenter
l'investissement pour la santé pour les
programmes sociaux pour les services aux
canadiens on va maintenir des
investissements pour les services les
les programmes qui donne le service au
kenya va être protégé mais le gaspillage
le march madness le fait que beaucoup d
édifice fédéral vie de passion pour s'en
occuper
on peut régler cette situation baisser
les coûts de la gomme en mai assuré que
les services continuent d'augmenter sur
l'avortement monsieur chien vous répéter
que vous allez voter contre tout projet
de loi qui ramènerait cette question là
mais est ce que vous vous engagez à
offrir à aider les provinces à offrir de
meilleurs services pour l'avortement
alors j'ai toujours dire que les lois
les accès ne changeant pas à et nous
avons continué d'augmenter les
investissements pour les systèmes de
santé de chaque province et alors elle
peut avoir confiance que goulon
constructeur va continuer de remonter
les dépenses parce que j'ai cette rude
ou éternue surdoué qu'aujourd'hui il
avait il s'est engagé à s'asseoir avec
le premier ministre higgs justement pour
s'assurer que le nouveau produit plus
offrir de meilleurs services en dehors
des hôpitaux est ce que vous vous
engagez à faire la même chose
oui monsieur mais monsieur trudeau les
hypocrites parce que et là utilisé sept
ans je peux faire
les pratiques parce que quand c'était
une première liste libérale monsieur
trudeau n'a fait à dire y ait une
affaire rien alors c'est une question de
gestion provinciale les tous les
premiers ministres des provinces peu
savent que je vais à augmenter les
investissements
chaque année minimum 3 % mais est ce que
vous pourriez pénalisé par exemple les
provinces qui ne suivent pas les règles
de ce sujet là on va toujours assuré que
les provinces suivre les règles suivent
le la loi sur la santé du canada ça
c'est un engagement très clair
beaucoup de gens monsieur chien en
terminant disent que la campagne était
très toxique
il ya eu beaucoup de faussetés qui ont
été dites beaucoup d' attaques
personnelles
quelle part de responsabilité vous
prenez dans ce ton de campagne qu'on n'a
jamais vus vraiment au canada chaque
jour j'ai fait des annonces positives
pour expliquer mon plafond mamés idée
mais solutions pour rendre la vie plus
abordable pour laisser plus d'argent
dans les poches des canadiens
je suis concentré sur une campagne
positive je dois noter que c'est le
gouvernement libéral c'est le parti
libéral qui a fait les attaques qui à
faire les attaques personnelles qu'il
faut féministe c'est mais c'est vrai
qu'il a menti elle a régalé les
quotidiennes dans les yeux elle a dit
que les allégations dans l'agglo mais a
été fort c'est un mensonge
vous accusez les libéraux de vouloir
légaliser les drogues dures
est-ce que vous engagez à retirer ses
publicités
parce que justice que monsieur tron
lui-même a dit qu'il va qu'ils ne
peuvent pas pas les grises et à ce
moment pas tout de suite tout beaucoup
de ces candidats à dire c'est sûr a dit
publiquement qu'elle veut légaliser les
les trucs dur à une politique qui était
passé à leur convention est aussi le
député libéral sur le comité de la santé
a imposé une rapport qui as une de ses
recommandations sur la libération des
deux leaders
mais je ne l'aurais jamais être très
très clair on lui en anglais le père
forcer ses députés ces candidats de
retirer leur proposition
alors c'est important que les tous les
canadiens savent que c'est après les
élections comme ça on a vu avec eu
d'intrusion l'histoire qu'il dit une
chose pendant les campings effet une
chose après les élections alors monsieur
chien aussi la fin de la campagne juste
six jours va souhaiter une bonne fin de
campagne
merci